hey girlies welcome back to Elle Fame
before I get into this video properly
there's a bit of news I want to talk
about because I'm gonna be releasing
three videos of elf fame today which
makes this a pretty historical day in my
normally not so filled with that much
content channel because three videos is
quite a lot and it's not exactly what I
was planning to do but we're coming
really close to the deadline and as I'm
uploading this as well as the next video
of elf fame as well as the final
cinematic video of the POV it should be
the 30th of June if all goes well and if
it doesn't go that well it's gonna have
to be the very early morning of the 1st
of July because the 10:00 a.m. at least
here in Holland is the deadline for the
contest that I'm making this for hence
why I am really trying to push this in
order to get it out and why this
eventually turned out to not exactly go
to planning though I still had a plan
for this and I'll definitely be able to
get this out for the contest it's just
not as neatly as I normally would wish
to do so and that's also why these
videos even though I did still want to
put them out since I have the time
lapses saved and I wanted to make it
into some form of content here they're
just not really up to the normal
standards perhaps I am kind of winging
this commentary as much as I was winning
the making of this restaurant over here
and so yeah it might be a little bit
different than usual and I just wanted
to talk about that and let you guys know
that is the case and yeah that is
basically that's quick notification at
the beginning of this video now to
actually talk about what I am doing in
this video I'll come back to the idea of
the contest and like the general
planning for today a bit later but just
a introduction of what I'm making in
this video I wanted to have one last
building in this town which is can be a
pretty large building it's actually
gonna bring the town into the theme park
setting a little bit more by just giving
it at least a bit of a purpose in
existence here by adding a restaurant in
there which people can actually not go
to because it's not gonna be a
functional restaurant but at least it's
gonna keep the idea of this being an
actual functional theme park
little bit alive brings the town a
little bit more into the forefront of
the path in front of it and it's also a
really good way to get that sort of last
lowest building because of like I've
said before I wanted these buildings to
kind of sit on top of the hill but also
kind of rise as they come closer to the
castle to get that I sort of build up of
buildings toward the highest point like
the main weenie of this landscape in and
this is going to be the lowest building
of this area and so I wanted to connect
it a bit more to the path and to the
landscape around it to not make the town
seem too disconnected from the rest of
the landscape and the restaurant just
seemed like a really fun a good way to
get that going and also a great way to
get some new ideas for design and also
ways to get tables and chairs in and
things like that which will also play
quite a role in the second part of this
video like like I'll get back to messing
with benches and lights that kind of
idea get into path elements and
decorating paths a bit more which is
also pretty interesting and the design
for the restaurant itself is pretty
simple though it's very similar to what
I've already been doing at this point in
time the only major difference I would
say is that I try to avoid the big
galleries of arches that I have with the
other buildings I'll still have some
arches on this building in the future
and I'll build those in a few minutes in
the time-lapse but it's not as much as
like I would usually do a lot of the
focus on this building is actually on
the details on the walls using all sorts
of door pieces and other details that
work to get the colors and textures in
as well as the windows and just the
general detail on the walls instead of
having these large galleries of arches
and pillars that's the general idea
behind it because in the end I did have
to fit a restaurant in here and just by
having those arches in a building you
get a really open building but you also
lose a lot of like indoor space that I
wanted to keep in this building since
obviously it's gonna be a restaurant or
at least it's gonna be a make-believe
restaurants that's the idea generally
and now just to add a bit more of that
that arch action that I had in the other
buildings I didn't want to add a couple
arches on the outside so here it goes
that's but at the moment it also looks
like a pretty simple building in terms
of shape much like the other buildings
just with a simple gable roof some
details and a very rectangular shape and
I didn't want to do something about it I
wasn't entirely sure how I wanted to
tackle this I didn't have any exact plan
it was more or less just trial and error
and see what would kind of work but I
wanted to make something that would not
only give like nice entrance into the
restaurants and have something that
sticks out of it and draws you into the
restaurants but also something that adds
a bit of heights to the building like at
this point I didn't feel much of a
connection with the rest of the town
which is quite high and raised on top of
that Hill and I wanted to add something
which would be the highest point of this
building to kind of connect it to the
rest of the area which we just look a
little nicer if you look at the town
from view in the distance like the other
side of this little valley here so I
wanted to make an entrance on top of
which I can actually place a tower to
get that height in and also some extra
detail and that is basically the idea
behind the roof I'm adding over here it
generally follows pretty much the exact
same style of what I've been doing
before just with some slight variations
on general themes but I wanted to bring
out a tower in the front in the middle
of this little section to get that extra
height going in the building and I kind
of skipped a section in the time-lapse
as well over there I think it was
actually a section with a lot of trial
and error and messing with different
things to try and get the shape of the
tower that I wanted but the most
important thing is that it kind of
sticks out of that roof there and has
another one of these very typical elvish
spires to it because in the end this
building as well is quite quite simple
actually it could almost pass for a
general alpine building except for like
the very details and I wanted another
accents to bring out the elvish elements
and theming without making it too
outlandish and making it too
ridiculously Elvin Elvin themed so I
really figured
a very good way to get the Elven theme
in here would also be to add another
spire with the need more elven like
touches to it and that's basically that
idea I had this open for quite a while
and then I figured it wouldn't really
look that good when it's open like it
just looks kind of awkward with the roof
behind it so I did in the end figure
that I wanted to put some walls on the
tower and make it a closed tower instead
but also with just the spire it kind of
looked very empty and it didn't really
look the way I exactly 102 so I decided
to add some dormers on all four sides of
the tower to make it a little bit more
similar to the elven towers that I
already have just with a general
different look to the spire actually one
of the reasons why I like spire so much
is that they draw a lot of attention to
like one part of the building so even if
the building like the rest of the
building looks quite similar to what you
already have
the spire like brings out a lot of the
general idea of what a building looks
like and the general shape and there is
a lot of variations that you can make
with spires so there's just it's just a
really nice way to add a unique kind of
touch to each building even if the
buildings for the rest of the Ovitz are
pretty similar to other buildings in a
certain rural section of the park or a
certain theme that you have and
especially with fantasy themes like this
but it also kind of counts for like
castle towers or churches there's a lot
of different variations that you can go
for anyway I also wanted to add a bit
more foliage in here one of the reasons
that I also like like the elven theme I
guess is that it gives a lot of freedom
to kind of mess with fantasy ideas that
you don't really see that much in real
life so I've wanted to get a lot of
foliage into these buildings to well get
rid a bit of all that whiteness that you
can't really get rid of but at least
muscular bits buy any extra color into
the building so figured it would be nice
to add a quick blunter to that part
especially since I for all the hanging
baskets that I have at this point I
didn't really have many like flower
boxes and it was really nice to add that
I have no idea what's up with the path
over here though it for some reason the
path didn't want to connect to anything
so even if I wanted to I actually
couldn't have added
any kind of restaurant to this that was
actually functional because this part is
for some reason completely glitched out
and has really weird never had that
before actually and never had it off to
this it's just sort of like a one-time
weird glitch thing might actually have
to do with the terraforming underneath
it anyway moving on I wanted to add some
extra tables and chairs to this
restaurant and try some new very quick
designs though very quick design quickly
turned into a very light spree of going
through all the different pieces in the
game to try and see what can actually
work for the tables and chairs and ended
up just going with a very simple idea
that I started off with in the end just
a quick letter to make the end of the
chair and the the wooden bracket piece I
think it's it's got a name that sounds
something like that as the the bottom of
the chair which works pretty well it's
quite a small chair it's not too big and
too bulky it's definitely not the most
beautiful chair but I guess it's
somewhat believable and what's kind of
funny is that before I've gone for
tables with the Ponton piece as the
whites sort of table and I've also gone
for the wooden tables which are pretty
small but I figured now it would be kind
of nice to have the fountain as the
table and use the wood as a sort of
tablecloth to get that general
restaurant feeling in there and another
idea which actually works pretty alright
and I'm actually quite happy with how it
turned out though it's not exactly
perfect for the Elven theme I think it
can actually work out pretty well for
more tropical themes is a wooden parasol
on top of the tables to block out the
Sun I guess which is not gonna be really
necessary but it just gives more of a
restaurant feeling to it just makes the
general restaurant look a bit cozier I
think so I wanted to add those as well
and yeah that is basically that sort of
general planning for as much as I had
any planning at all to begin with that
is which really wasn't that much
actually get a lot of questions about
this so I think it's interesting to talk
about it I get a lot of questions about
like how much planning I do whether I
draw out things before I start building
them or like how much of an idea I have
of what I'm gonna build before I start
doing it well for one I don't usually
draw it out because I'm just not that
could
throwing and it would take just to do so
and I don't really have the patience for
it but I do have to say even though I
don't really like planning out
physically I do usually want to have
like a good idea of what I want to do
like a general idea of I'm gonna place a
certain building here and it's kind of
gonna look in this certain way I don't
really like starting before I have like
a general picture in my head of what I
want to go for but for many of the small
things and just quite often anyway I
just more or less wing it and I think
it's just most important to kind of know
what general direction you want to go
into and like the very precise things
you can always mess with a bit in the
game like throwing it out kind of works
but it never really works for the
specifics of what pieces you want to use
or how you want to have like specific
details to look like especially with the
limited pieces that we have in the game
at the moment so I think it just really
helps to have a general idea of what
you're going for it to not get
completely lost and it's also really
easy to lose motivation if you don't
have like an idea of what you're what
you want to go for because you know you
start judging your project by what it
looks like at the moment which is very
often unfinished and very ugly but if
you really have an idea of what you want
to go for you you more or less have a
goal even though there's no strictly
speaking now goal in a game like this I
find it just kind of helps to keep you
going and that's just kind of why I want
to keep a general idea of what I'm
building but it is largely just winging
it there's also just you know time
involved I don't I don't want to spend
too much time on all of this and how in
this well this particular thing I
couldn't spend too much time on it's
because well there was a deadline and it
is actually very close and I can't
really well afford to spend a lot of
time planning things ahead I just more
or less have to hope that it's all gonna
work out alright and that is basically a
lot of what I'm doing I mean in the end
you can plan things well I had as much
as you can but there will also always be
things that you can't really plan ahead
or like things that you discover that
you weren't figuring beforehand and I
think a lot of the fun in the game is
also just playing it and
just experimenting with things and
seeing what you can do at the spots
instead of having these enormous plans
beforehand that you have to follow very
strictly now moving on to the last parts
of this video there were some small path
elements that I wanted to add around
here and most of it is just builds out
of these blanks which is kind of a new
thing actually for my lights I've never
done that before but they work really
well for it especially since they're so
small you can get more into detail and
like more unique ideas of what you want
your lights to look like but the base is
just very simple straight posts with two
lanterns on top of it and this is gonna
be the sort of fancy lantern that I'm
gonna have around the park but I also do
want to change the style up quite a bit
I I think when it comes to lights and
fences people are very like it's very
easy to make one and use that throughout
the park but when it comes to things
like this I just think it's best when
you switch them up between different
areas or even on one path just to make
everything look a bit more interesting
and less predictable so I had I wanted
to have at least two different light
designs that I could switch through in
this park and just about three different
fence designs there's this wooden fence
which was a nightmare to build never
again well maybe once again but I'm not
really sure if I really want to do that
and there's gonna be some other offence
things that I'll get into in the next
video and of course some planters and
let's get some planters in as well and
same kind of counts over here I wanted
to get some planted in with different
flowers here and there and that's
generally how this area worked out it's
a pretty simple area doesn't really rely
on a lot of scenery to look good it's
just all abouts the path interaction
with the coaster and a coastal layout
itself so I was quite happy just
decorating it with a bit of simple path
elements like lights and benches and
fences and have some simple foliage
around that and pretty much leave it at
that felt pretty safe just going about
it that way in this case now coming back
to the final thing I wanted to talk
about very quickly since the time-lapse
is almost ending
I forgot to mention that this video and
the last video are going to kind of
connect since they were recorded after
each other but there was still quite a
bit of things done after that period of
time so while these are the last videos
of time lapses of this park
the rest will finna be finished outside
of videos and you'll really see the
final results in the final video and
that is basically it so I hope to see
you guys in the next video where I'll
more or less continue this part of the
park and this commentary as well so
thank you guys for watching